what's up it's me bunsing
ever wonder what it would be like if all
your favorite cartoons existed in the
same universe
lincoln loud could go visit jimmy
neutron and who knows maybe danny
phantom babysits the rugrats when he's
not hunting ghosts
aside from the odd crossover special the
closest we'll
ever get to seeing all of our favorite
nickelodeon characters hanging out
together are these hidden easter eggs
and references to
other knick cartoons most of which you
probably never noticed from hidden
sponges
to familiar names and faces these easter
eggs make us wonder what other
connections exist between our favorite
shows
awesome this is gonna be great
loud house is full of references to all
kinds of shows but it just might
set the record for most nicktoons
referenced in one scene
in the episode link or swim the show
manages to reference
five other nickelodeon favorites while
going for a swim in the local pool
link and his sisters get kicked out for
getting a little too rowdy
and disrupting the senior citizen swim
right after they leave we get a good
look at the group of seniors crowding
around the pool
and they look awfully familiar can you
guess them all
clockwise from the top we have lou
pickles from rugrats uncle iro from
avatar the last airbender
miss bitter from invader zim grandpa
phil from hey arnold and winfred fowle
from jimmy neutron
i guess now we know where senior
citizens in the nicktoon universe go to
retire
so that's it then no more pool for the
louds
you might not have noticed but spongebob
squarepants has actually made quite a
few appearances in the loud house
while there hasn't been an official
crossover between these two shows
yet the creators of loud house love
giving subtle nods to our favorite sea
dwelling sponge
in the loud house episode attention
deficit lincoln feels like he's not
getting enough attention from his own
family
when he asks them for help with his
model volcano and speaking of attention
if you're not paying enough of it you
might miss this next easter egg when
lincoln's parents finally help him with
the volcano there's a little something
on his tray of materials that stands out
see the little yellow sponge we wouldn't
be surprised if that was an intentional
reference to spongebob
since it's not the first time loud house
has alluded to the iconic nickelodeon
cartoon
the disguise is working patrick i mean
patricia
jimmy neutron and his friends end up
visiting what appears to be bikini
bottom
in this next easter egg during the
two-part jimmy neutron special
operation rescue jet fusion jimmy sheen
and carl have to dive into the ocean in
order to retrieve a tracking device from
the bottom of the sea
as they approach the device they swim
past what looks to be a pineapple
sitting on the ocean floor
and who do we know that lives in a
pineapple under the sea
spongebob squarepants of course what
else would a pineapple be doing at the
bottom of the ocean
now that we have a fancy ghost sucking
device we're going to hunt ghosts
all over dingsdale did you know that
danny phantom appears in a couple of
episodes of the fairly oddparents
in the episode poulter geeks timmy finds
out that his parents used to work as a
ghost hunting duo called the poulter
geeks way back in the 1980s
the idea for the episode is most
obviously an homage to the movie
ghostbusters
but it's also a little nod to fairly
oddparents's creator butch hartman's
other show danny phantom dany is also a
ghost hunter although he's part ghost
himself
which is why you can see him in a tiny
cameo in this episode
you wouldn't catch it if you weren't
paying attention but at one point we see
danny phantom on a monitor behind
timmy's parents with the label
wanted flashing underneath him uh-oh
looks like the poultry geeks can't tell
the good
ghosts from the bad ones well it could
be timmy
after all there's a pantsless dog and a
floating kid
while danny shows up in dimsdale on the
fairly oddparents
the references go both ways as one
episode of danny phantom contains an
easter egg tied to timmy's favorite
intergalactic superhero
in the episode what you want dany and
tucker go to the movie theater
remember those and while they're hanging
in the theater we get a glimpse of a
crash nebula
arcade game in the background behind
them crash nebula of course is a
fictional superhero from the fairly
oddparents who has his own tv show
and apparently crash nebula is so
popular he crossed over into danny
phantom's home turf with his own arcade
game
it could be just a little inside
reference for fans of both shows but we
love the idea that both danny
and timmy watch the same tv shows well
this is gravely important
to me this next one's a bit of a mind
bender
danny phantom makes a small cameo in yet
another episode of the fairly oddparents
but this time he appears within crash
nebula the show within the show that
timmy turner can't get enough of
in the fairly oddparents episode crash
nebula we get to see the origin story
for crash nebula one of timmy's favorite
superheroes
at one point you can briefly see dany
phantom on the back of a comic book
held by spriggs be back crash nebula's
alter ego
so to recap danny phantom shows up in
dimsdale but also pops up within timmy's
favorite tv show crash nebula
which also exists in danny phantom's
universe it seems pretty safe to say
that both the fairly odd parents
and danny phantom exist in the same
universe but with all these references
back and forth and within
the real question is who's visiting
who's universe
okay who's been messing with the ghost
portal
but butch hartman also made sure to
reference nickelodeon cartoons
other than the ones with his name in the
credits the fairly oddparents also
contains easter eggs that reference
spongebob
in the episode wish fixers timmy gets
punished for making too many
bad wishes one of those bad wishes
asking for a pair of turbo cheese pants
cosmo hilariously called come on boy
squarepants
then in the episode something's fishy
timmy and his fairy godparents explore
the deep sea
and discover the lost city of atlantis
at one point the king of atlantis says
that although mostly our diet consists
of crabs
starfish and the occasional underwater
squirrel
this is a pretty clear reference to the
denzians of bikini bottom
in particular mr krabs patrick and sandy
the king then burps up what looks like a
squirrel tail we sure hoped that wasn't
sandy where do you think you're going i
was just no
you're not if you thought that was a
well-hidden easter egg just wait till
you hear about this next one
spongebob was actually referenced in
another nickelodeon show before its
first episode even aired
in the hey arnold episode weighing
harold there's a scene where arnold
walks into a comic book shop
and in the background behind him you can
see a comic book titled spongebob
to top it off another two comic books in
the background form the image of
nickelodeon's cat dog
this episode aired on april 7th 1999
almost a month before spongebob's tv
premiere in may of 1999.
that means that technically this is the
first reference to spongebob
ever made on nickelodeon oh gee mom and
dad have grounded me from watching tv
in the fairly oddparents special channel
chasers we see the show parodying
a whole host of other tv shows
everything from fat man to the jetsons
in this episode timmy's parents forbid
him from watching any television
after he tries a little too hard to
emulate his favorite series
so what does timmy do he asks his fairy
godparents for a magical remote that can
take him
inside the tv so he can experience all
of his favorite tv shows first hand his
wish ends up causing unexpected
consequences of course but we can't
really blame timmy
where can we get ourselves a remote like
that hopping from channel to channel
eventually takes timmy cosmo and wanda
into a show called carpet critters which
is a clear reference to nickelodeon's
rugrats
right down to the animation style and
theme tune
um there's a yummy chocolate pudding
downstairs in the kitchen way before the
fairly oddparents was throwing in easter
eggs to other nicktoons left and right
rugrats featured a little crossover with
another nickelodeon cartoon called
ah real monsters in the episode ghost
story the rugrats are taking turns
telling scary stories
over the course of the tale the kids end
up bumping into ickis crum
and oblina from ah real monsters
although the two groups get off on the
wrong foot the monsters end up helping
the rugrats give angelica a good scare
this one is notable because it's also
the very first time that characters from
different knick shows crossed over
pretty cool and as we've seen the
tradition has carried on strong with
newer shows like the loud house paying
homage to many of the shows we've talked
about
and then some here's one somebody didn't
finish
squidward smells good
which of these easter eggs do you like
most leave a comment below and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button for
more amazing videos like this
thanks for watching